insider options trading yeah
can you break that i know you've talked
about it before
but for people that are watching this
one can you kind of like break down like
how
you experienced that and how you
discovered everything that went down
yeah so i've already
explained what a put option is right
just to clarify in case you're gonna
make a clip a put option is a derivative
security whereby
if the underlying security moves a small
percentage
the put option will move a massive
percentage and
with puts you're betting that the
underlying security is going to go down
it's the opposite of a call option
in the days before 9 11
the average daily volume of the put
options on the airlines went
through the bloody roof
when 911 happened and the stock market
was halted and the
stock market was reopened days later
and the underlying securities had
collapsed
those put options had gone up
thousands of percents
small investments were worth millions
it was headline news it's on youtube
you can find it about insider option
trading
and the guy said on the headline news in
america
this has to be the terrorists
the only people could possibly know were
the terrorists
this is insider terrorist trading
these trades will be traced and we will
find out who these bastards are
paraphrasing of course so it completely
disappears out of the news
now you know options is something i've
been on for many years of my life i'm
thinking what is going on with this
this is insane i've never seen anything
like this before in my life
headline news push gone
years later
i'm in a maximum security madison street
jail phoenix arizona reading a book by
david ike i think
perhaps alice in wonderland 911
and his his research
had found that those trades
had been traced to a brokerage
that was run by xcia
so not only had they known about it
they had profited from it everybody
who knew about those trades at the time
was visited by the feds and deputized
which meant if you ever speak to these
trades about anyone outside
of this interview today you are going to
prison
for years of your life so that
completely i mean if people google it
i'm not put out all the names involved
if people google it
you can see all the names involved i
don't want to get it too complicated for
people
um but it gets really deep now is there
actual proof that there's xcia people
that were in charge of the banks that
were doing these trades
oh yeah is this something like cause i
know david ike he i mean talk about
being connected to some bat [__]
craziness yeah i know he's connected to
some crazy [__] yeah i agree 100
but every time you see him in his name
that people are talking about reptilians
and stuff
i agree 100 that david has some
conspiracy theories that people
would consider crazy but
this has been verified by a number of
other independent researchers as well
okay um it's been discussed on rt quite
a lot
and uh i urge people to go on go online
and check it out themselves
i'm just putting it in right now on my
computer
to try and get the name of that
brokerage
uh max kaiser he's a guy who's done a
lot on it
on rt max
kaiser because he was involved with
those brokers as well here we go um
max kaiser and guest talk about 911
insider trading oh yeah here it is
there it is right
so it was it was very obvious that
advanced knowledge of the attacks was
circulating amongst traders
and this insider trading happened days
leading up to the attacks
buzzy crongguard k-r-o-n-g-a-r-d
deputy chairman of the cia
was the former head of alex brown
and alex brown was the company that had
i think
the majority of the options transactions
went
for them this says i used to work for
buzzy alex brown i still keep in touch
with my former colleagues
some of whom were buzzing about the
action in the putter options on the
airlines
additionally a company i started in
la.com had been sold to wall street
brokerage a few months before the
attacks
and the company had relocated their
acquisition to the top floor of the
world trade center
i was in touch with employees who were
also buzzing about the put option frenzy
in airline stocks
and they cited alex brown as a major
source
i urge people to research it there's a
lot more names involved there's a lot
more companies involved
and there are some articles that really
laid down but just off the top of my
head right now i can't find them
it's [__] crazy man that [__] is
some that's some terrifying stuff and no
one it's something that no one really
talks about
because the people who did the trades
would go to prison
and it goes right against you know
what was it pink floyd said mother
should i trust the government
[Laughter]
the government does not want you to hear
it mainstream media is owned by
you know the same corporations around
the government there you go you're not
going to get it apart from
independent researchers here and there
my whole like overview of this whole
situation with the stock market is that
the normalization of the internet and
everyone having access to so much
information and everyone just living on
these
on these devices 24 7. it's made
it's made it harder for the government
and corporations to keep secrets
you know it's kind of it's made
everything more transparent
which is made like previously like if
you even go 10 years ago when
or 20 years ago when no one had iphones
or people weren't living on the compute
on
online i'm sure far
less far less
people understood the stock market than
they do today
and now because of something like this
because now you have this crazy news
story about a bunch of kids on reddit
that are manipulating and making these
people lose billions now everybody wants
to learn how the stock market works
and it's gonna it's gonna shine a light
on
all this shady [__] that happens all the
time that's
normal for the stock market okay so what
you said about technology advancing is
true
but with the stock market there's
nothing new under the sun
so when you see this deluge
of novices wanting to learn about the
stock market
we saw exactly the same thing during the
dot-com bubble
and we know when that deluge happens
that the stock market is getting near a
top
because who's left to buy after those
what the professionals would view as
idiots
once that last wave of money comes in
from your barber from your granny
from you know whoever little reddit
investors
once all that money's in who else is
left then
to sell shows too because the insiders
are constantly unloading
stock on novice investors it's a
disinformation game
when you read something in online
or in a financial publication that says
this company's doing great you should
buy shares in it
that information is being put out there
because
someone is trying to sell you their
shares
inside there's a constantly just pumping
news stories out telling you how great
they're doing
how strong our earnings growth is how
sales revenue is going to go through the
roof in the coming years
we've got contracts with china all these
stories are coming out
all the time to suck
people into buying the shares they are
selling to them
for every buyer there's a seller and
when that last wave of suckers comes in
it's getting near a market top and those
people
you know your barbers your shoeshine
person
when they get wiped they'll go back to
doing what they're doing and they wish
they never got involved in the stock
market in the first place i see it over
and over again
such a crazy game it's just like going
to the casino
i've never been i've never been into it
i've never bought shares and like
individual
pic i've never like individually picked
stocks or day trade or whatever
you know just like you know index funds
or whatever passive stuff but
man it's addicting once you once you get
into that you start like watching it
every day
watching your numbers go up and down
short-term trading definitely
so again this is just an educational
video this is not investment advice
if you put some money away every month
in a fund that's highly rated and is
safe
over time you'll see that go up and down
up and down but over time
you will make a much higher rate of
return than you would
than having that money just parked in
the bank at a very low interest rate
but you've got to be able to stomach
those ups and downs if you're putting
the money in every month you're doing
what's dollar
cost averaging so when it goes down you
buy more
automatically when it goes up you buy
less but your growth is right there
that's the sensible way to do it for
novice investors
foreign